It was a little past
midnight when I got the call asking me
to knock doors for Hillary Clinton.
The caller was my friend Jason, who was
working on the campaign in Pennsylvania.
He wanted me to take time off of my
job to help with the final push.
Why me, I asked him?
Isn't there someone else more qualified?
At the time, I was serving as
a policy advisor at the White House.
And what I was actually wondering was,
isn't there someone else
less overqualified?
>> [LAUGH]
>> I was working on change at scale.
If I got this policy done
on self-driving cars,
we would potentially be saving
over 40,000 lives per year.
And if I took time off of work,
I would knock how many doors?
I also didn't know the first thing about
talking to a stranger at their front door.
What I knew about was policy.
The decision seemed obvious,
I could add more value right where I was.
Sorry, I said.
But Jason didn't give up.
You want to make a difference,
come knock doors.
I didn't believe him, but I went anyways,
because a friend had asked.
And I am so glad that I did.
Because for a long time I thought that
the way to create change was top down, and
that meant advising government
leaders at McKinsey or
creating policy at the White House,
not knocking on doors in Pennsylvania.
Maybe some of you have a similar view, But
I want to talk to you about why
bottom up change matters too.
Knocking on doors can change elections,
change you, and change your world today.
So what does it mean to knock on doors?
Knocking on doors is about
getting into a neighborhood and
going door to door to talk to voters.
It has two primary purposes,
persuading voters and increasing turnout.
Knocking on doors might feel old school,
but it makes sense.
Think about how you change someone's mind.
It's face to face through
a relationship built on trust.
Knocking on doors relies on both of
those strategies for persuading voters.
It's also an effective tool for
driving turnout.
Talking to voters can provide
the nudge that they need
to actually get out there and
vote on election day.
I remember the first time I knocked
on doors I thought, this works.
I remember the woman in Pittsburg
who told me she wasn't going to
vote because she didn't know
where her polling location was.
Just the kind of
information I had on hand.
At another home, a man with a golden
retriever stood at the door and
said he wasn't going to vote
because Hillary had it in the bag.
I showed them the latest polling
numbers and he promised me he'd vote.
After that experience,
I dug into the research and
found out that two decades of studies
have shown that the surest way to change
an election outcome is to have
high quality door knocking.
Talking to voters and getting out
the vote can make all the difference,
especially when margins are tight.
Take Virginia.
In 2017, a heated local race
between Democrat Shelly Simonds and
Republican David Yancey ended in a tie.
They ended up deciding the winner
by pulling a name out of a hat.
That one race resulted in Republicans
maintaining control of the state house.
That means one vote could
have changed what healthcare,
wages, schools looked like for the state.
And not every election is won by one vote,
but
every election cycle there
are races with razor thin margins.
Knocking on doors is also essential for
national victories.
In 2016, 120,000,000 votes were cast for
the presidential election, but
just 107,000 of those votes in three
states determined the outcome.
107,000 votes.
To put that in perspective,
if each of us at the business school
had spoken with just 125 voters,
which by the way you can do in one day,
we would've spoken with all of them.
Yes, elections feel big and daunting,
but ultimately they're won by
relatively small numbers, and
those small numbers have huge impact.
Knocking on doors can also change you.
Let's face it, it can be intimidating
to knock on a stranger's door.
But we also know that it's in moments
of discomfort that we grow the most.
And you'll grow tremendously,
both as a leader and as a citizen.
Today, our world is not set up to interact
with people who are different from us.
Instead of taking public transportation,
we take Ubers.
Instead of going to the movies,
we opt for Netflix in bed.
And when we want a cup of sugar, we don't
go to our neighbors, we go to Instacart.
Knocking doors gets you
out of that bubble.
No two conversations I've had at
the door have ever been the same.
As a result, I've practiced and
built a range of skills.
I have more empathy after listening
to the stories of strangers.
I take more risk after rejection after
rejection at the door, and I'm much more
comfortable in difficult conversations
after navigating some hostile attitudes.
All of those skills translate in
a really real way to the workplace.
If you're an entrepreneur,
you'll be that much better at
uncovering the needs of your customers.
If you're an investor, you'll be more
persuasive when it comes to raising money.
For me, as a policymaker,
I'm much better at analyzing the effects
of my policies and programs on a range of
citizens outside of my immediate circle.
I'm also a more informed voter.
While I might not be personally struggling
with access to healthcare, thank you,
Stanford Cardinal Care,
after a conversation in Virginia Beach
with a woman whose daughter was
struggling with diabetes, I have this
window into how healthcare policy affects
lives and why it matters to go for it.
So knocking on doors doesn't just
change elections, it also changes you.
Here at the Business School
my peers often say,
I want to make a difference, but let me
focus on making it to the top first, and
then I'll do a lot with that money,
power, and position to do a lot of good.
But we're at a critical moment right now.
On climate change, on health care,
on the future of our workforce,
our democratic processes are crumbling.
Some things aren't reversible, and so
we have to start changing our world today.
When I came to campus back in the fall,
I was excited to be surrounded by
my peers who were eager to get
out there and make a difference.
When the 2018 midterm
election rolled around,
100 students expressed
interest in getting involved.
But on the day that it came down
to actually knocking doors,
only two others students showed up.
The district we were knocking in was Josh
Harder's, in Central Valley, California.
He won the election, but it was so
close it took them a week to call it.
Our door knocking made a difference.
Very few of us are probably going to
knock on doors as our full-time job.
That's likely not the way that we aspire
to change lives, change organizations, and
change the world.
But there isn't a trade-off here,
you can pursue your
career of top down change while
still knocking on doors today.
They aren't mutually exclusive.
In fact, they're mutually beneficial.
We have an election coming up in 2020.
Pick a race, it could be something local,
it could be for
the next president of the United States.
And commit to getting into a neighborhood,
even if just once,
and knock on some doors.
I'll see you out there, thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]